nous sommes à l'aube de la télévision
puisque tout simplement les pionniers
son vivant et se porte très bien
pierre saba il a été décoré hier par le
président mitterrand nous parlions il ya
un instant de jacqueline joubert qui est
quelque part dans cette maison on parle
de nous et nous recevons pierre tchernia
alors quand on dit pionniers vous
éprouvez un sentiment de fierté ou
prenez un coup de vieux non ça me fait
rire parce que j'ai l'impression d'être
dans un album de lucky luke est d'aller
défricher l'oklahoma vagues ont bâché
n'ont autant que je travaille moi tout
va bien ce qui serait plus rentable et
que j'ai plus eu l'occasion de
travailler depuis jamais venir reconnu
alger ou au but où est-ce que c'est dans
ce métier comme dans d'autres je veux
parler des artistes qui fréquenta scène
on a du mal à décrocher surtout du monde
parce que notre raison notre double
raison de vivre c'est l'amour et l'amour
du métier alors il faut que les deux
choses de l'autre côté ça va très bien
tu es ce que vous soupçonniez
l'importance que la télévision prendrait
à l'époque avec tous vos camarades
non absolument pas on pensait pas du
tout à ça si on s'était posé la question
n'aurait certainement prévu des
développements considérables
on aurait pensé que ça allait faire
comme la radio mais on pensait pas sa
williams parce que on était trop peureux
de s'amuser à faire de la télévision
nous faisons des métiers de plaisir on
cherche à faire plaisir aux personnes
qui nous regardent
il faut qu'on en prenne nous-mêmes et la
petite équipe du journal télévisé qui
travaillent dans des conditions insensé
songez que de 49 à 54
on n'avait que des caméra 16 mm muette
d'amateurs on n'a jamais enregistré une
déclaration ministérielle mais née à lac
étaient ces gens ces jeunes gens dont
vous parlez dont vous faisiez partie qui
se lancer dans la télévision c'étaient
des déçus du cinéma peut il ya eu de
dieu de tout ça bat revenait de la radio
et la fonte des journal télévisé avec
des gens qui venaient de la radio mois
il se trouve que j'avais fait lydec et
puis que j'étais passé par la radio ou
club décès que du mayet m'avait entraîné
dans dans la bande de sa dague que sa
bague de m'a pris quand j'ai commencé le
télévisé je jouais en même temps à saint
germain des prés oui j'étais en même
temps comédien
voyez que on venait d'un peu partout il
ya eu certainement déçus du cinéma il ya
eu des parce que en 1900 les années 50
entrée dans le cinéma était très
difficile au moins aussi difficile que
la journée et il ya certainement des tas
de jeunes gens qui ont fait leur
carrière à la télévision prenait marcel
bluwal il raille un grand réalisateur de
cinéma
il s'est engagé dans la télévision il ya
fait merveilleusement sakaris et curieux
parce que vous le saunier ni un instant
à l'époque on était multi cartes vous
dira pas que vous étiez comédiens mais
aussi vous aviez fait lydec l'école de
cinéma et puis vous êtes fait du
journalisme aussi bien sûr j'en avais lu
au journal pendant cinq ans mais je
crois que dans nos métiers il faut
absolument être multi produits dits dans
les
elle est rendue si mes liens
multi-produits s'est exercée c'est à la
mode alors en cinquante ans on a fait le
bon que nous savons tous est ce que vous
pensez dans les 50 années qui viennent
nous ferons un bon encore plus important
où ça va se calmer un peu maintenant on
a fait l'essentiel sur le plan de sur le
plan de l'achat des récepteurs ça va se
calmer parce que actuellement kobe y
at-il de récepteurs il ya près de vingt
millions de récepteurs je croyais à 18 à
20 millions elle a pratiquement un par
foyer en voir en hd un deuxième pour
mettre dans la chambre des enfants
mais ce qui va ce bouleversant et se
développer c'est l'éclosion de toutes
les chaînes de télévision moi ce que
j'en veux plus en ce moment c'est les
gens qui vont avoir l'occasion de faire
une nouvelle chaîne de télévision
d'inventer des horaires de programmes
complètement différent non il ya tout un
tout un boulot à faire ce que je
souhaite simplement c'est que en se
multipliant elle ne s'investissent pas
trop travers merci pierre à vous ne
partez pas vous retrouve tournage fut
bien là il fait chaud il fait bon y en a
capella la lumière